ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls
it is time
for another 3D live stream I'm back
and uh give me a thumbs up if you can
hear me
because we got levels on my end but uh
do we have levels
on your end
y'all thank you for for hopping in with
me
um yeah good to see everybody good to
see y'all in the chat here
it's been a minute since I live stream I
think it's been since the last 3D
challenge back in uh
shoot I think the winter stream in April
maybe I don't know it's been a minute
all right it's been a minute and a lot
has happened in this time but for y'all
just joining me here's what we're doing
today all right I'll get into it uh
we're building Legos in 3D and we're
using a program called brick Link studio
it's linked in the description this is
not a sponsored video
I've just been having fun with this
software and I want to show it to you
guys
I want to show you how easy it is to
create Legos and how much fun it is as a
kid I was all about Legos and it's crazy
that Legos are still as popular as they
were back then if not more popular
um and it it it strikes a chord with me
um
a blast really is a blast and the cool
thing about Bricklink Studios they have
it's free first off they have all the
bricks ever
um all the pieces going back to the
beginning of Lego to the beginning of
time
um it's organized very nicely I'll we'll
dive into the program just a second but
what's cool about it is you can actually
do multiplayer you can have people join
your project file and you can build a
Lego together
um so that's what I want to do with you
guys today on the stream uh if you guys
are on Discord hit me up on Discord I'll
be checking my Discord DMS and um if
you're down to build
then I'll send you a password
essentially that way I kind of know who
who's in here I also I don't know how
many people can do this at once but I'll
be bringing people in
you know a little bit at a time here so
I'm excited for that
um what else okay so
I yeah it's been a minute right since
we've since we've streamed together
um scouty scouty's awake for the stream
that's good
it's a good thing
I saw wondrous was up in here
um a little bit ago
um yeah you know uh a lot has happened
in the last month or so since we've last
chatted
I can get into all that kind of
throughout the video but um I I just got
back from Japan about two weeks ago I
took a two-week break with my wife we
were there for our first year uh
anniversary
it was incredible
and what I'm doing here is directly
inspired by
the the places and the yeah all the
places that we went to in Japan
so first off
how did all this come about I found this
book
the Lego engineer
and it is an Incredible Book
you know look at all these fun little
micro builds I'm specifically going for
what's called micro scale Legos there's
minifigure scale where the minifigure is
like you know the size of the thing
you're building
um where skyscrapers can be this big and
then there's
um micro scale which this is all micro
skill obviously a cruise
a cruise boat like this is uh that's
pretty tiny that's pretty tiny I guess I
have an example here let me show you
I got this a while back
you can tell by all the dust on it but
this would be considered micro scale a
micro scale Lego
um and this actually yeah this is Tokyo
right
Mount Fuji Tokyo Tower
um a couple other buildings uh we got
like
Shinjuku here
temples
little Pagoda on the end here
and you see how it's just made from like
the most basic pieces
the minimal amount of pieces and that's
that's what I'm going for like look at
these soccer trees
look at these little trees
they're so cool
um
and it's awesome because you can go from
this program from Bricklink Studio
straight into blender straight into c4d
etc etc
um but back to this book so this book is
full of like all these really
awesome builds here and they're all
these micro builds
um
and they go through like different
architectural
um
kind of Feats of the world and um
they teach you how to build it too
there's instructions oh by the way
I bet you this book was made with
Bricklink Studio because you can
actually make instructions you can
export instructions for your builds here
it's ridiculous this program is so cool
again not sponsored by Bricklink studio
um but uh yeah I just discovered all
this stuff on my
on my uh
you know
exploring Legos and stuff so what we're
going to be doing let me switch over
here
uh this is Bricklink studio right we'll
get into it uh all the bricks ever
right we got tons of stuff
um
it's very simple it's very very simple
right and you just have a good old time
building whatever you want so
specifically I'm building some stuff
from my trip all right so I have all
this stuff saved out I got a ton of
references down here on different
versions different Lego builds but um
yeah the idea is like I just want to
recreate some of these spots out of
out of Legos and go for specifically
like little mini ones or mini versions
I'll show you what I have
so far
um let's load up
one of these guys
um
okay there's an altar here
so this one is
kind of
you know this is the reference
right each one of these little Alters
with a little flower
and um some Ceramics next to it on some
rock if it's kind of Mossy right so I
tried to to build this out in the most
yikes I'm trying to build this out in
the most minimal version possible with
different Lego pieces right and of
course you can choose the color in here
and you can even render out of this too
which is super cool
um let me see if
where is the render
section
here we go render boom render
yeah
yeah whatever save that to the desktop
you'll see it's really cool
look at this it's like hdri and
everything nice little shiny bricks
foreign
it's free it's so cool again not
sponsored linked down below so you guys
can hop in with me but you get the idea
um let me show you another one that I
did
we did
um
oh so this is from this book right the
uh the Lego engineer I put this together
based on instructions from this book and
yeah it's just like a little Japanese
train the shinkansen the bullet train
going through the countryside
um what else do we have
uh
oh so we were doing um I was hopping in
with uh Sam the guy the fifth place
winner from endless engines and we were
building together and trying to get
different versions and we did this uh
this little binocular thing you know
there's like a lookout on top of a
mountain we did this one based off of
this guy right here
and this took us like 15 minutes and we
were just throwing down parts and that's
what I want to do with you guys that's
what we'll do today is we'll we'll have
you guys in here if you want to build
with me
um hit me up on Discord okay
um if you go to my Discord server it is
also linked below
you'll find me on there you'll find me
on the server
um just DM me and then I'll give you a
password uh when it when it comes time
to start adding people to all this stuff
and then we were going for this Lantern
we're trying to figure out the lantern
where's that lane turn out yeah here we
go
this guy
right so trying to figure out the most
miniature minimalistic build for these
things uh what else do we have what else
do we have I won't get building here all
these vending machines yes I put these
vending machines together and these were
based off of tutorials
um from YouTube as well as a book that I
found at the bookstore called like uh
I think it's called
there's like 100 Lego ideas or something
like that
um I also have links for you guys
reference wise in the description below
for different websites that have been
really cool I think there's a website
literally called Lego ideas
um where you can like picture different
Lego ideas and whatnot but I want to do
yeah I thought these vending machines
were cool oh another crazy thing about
brickling studio is you can actually
check out you you you can hit um you can
hit like export or buy all these pieces
because Bricklink is a website it's like
secondhand Legos and you can buy the
individual pieces for every Lego ever so
you can put your idea together in
Bricklink you can check out and pay for
the parts and it'll put the shopping
cart together for you and then you'll
ship you all the Legos and then you can
build it yourself for real so that's
about the coolest thing in the world
um
vending machines yes and look they even
got little drinks inside of them too
isn't that sweet
oh so awesome so much fun
um and of course you can export this to
c4d you can export this to blender and
whatnot there might even be a blender
plug-in for this program what else I
feel like there was one more I'm working
on this one I'm trying to figure this
one out this one's tough
maybe this is one that we could do on
the stream together but it's uh it's
this guy we went to a Sumo tournament
right and you can kind of see the sumo
guy chilling down here
um but they had this giant Shinto Shrine
above the the I think it's called The
Dope the doyo or something it's
basically the the clay dirt area where
they they fight on and um
this is like already looking cool super
blocky I'd love to build this out as
minimally as possible
um
yeah
see I know I got more hold on
um
let's see let's see
um the
the there was a shrine I had of the
Zelda shrine
yeah this one
um
it's just a rock
and a couple lanterns
right from this one here
and
this one was my first one
this took me the longest
right but
it's super fun really really awesome
let's do a quick render and then we'll
start building
I'll get into something
I don't know what I'll build yet but
let's let's look at the chat here um
how you guys doing what's going on it's
been a minute
oh man that's a great idea custom
Christmas gift
I like that
I like that a lot
and no it's not 300 for five pieces the
Pieces cost like one cent two cents
some pieces really expensive pieces
might cost a dollar or two
but uh
you know so it's actually it's not that
bad
but yeah this is awesome
let's just let's build let's um
let's pick a new file here
I'm just rotating with you know left
click right click middle Mouse button is
pretty standard uh on the left we have
all of our bricks laid out here and I'll
kind of talk you guys through everything
as we do this
but it looks like
we have
one guy we got scouty Who's down to
build some Legos hang tight scouty
um we'll get you in here let me see
Brick link
let me sign in give me a second here
I just want to make sure you guys aren't
stealing my
my essence
come on now
all right sweet
all right we're logged in we got
brick link going let's do Build Together
all right so the ID
we're gonna get a password
um
message me on on Discord I will drop you
the password
um
as needed here guys
I'm gonna go ahead and Host this
your session's been created friends can
join you using your ID and session
password awesome all right let me get
started on my own and then we'll bring
some people in again you want to join me
hit me up on Discord
I'll say I'll share the password with
you guys
um
yeah we have I don't know what do you
guys want to do do you want to do like
this this building here this Archway do
we want to do a train like this perhaps
do we want to do this thatched roof
um
let's leave it up to a vote
in the chat and I know we can do a vote
thingy
uh start a poll let's do a poll
and we're gonna vote for uh which Lego
should I build
and
let's go ahead and add one
two
three and four that's confusing hold on
three and
four all right
and then I'm gonna line these up the
train will be one the roof will be two
the bridge will be three and let's do
this little Lantern thing as four
okay so here are your options one two
three and four
and we'll figure out which one
we want to build there's a pole going up
on the chat
take a look
vote for it and
um we're gonna build out one of these
oh y'all are about that train huh
functional house a functional house
that's so funny
oh one other thing you guys will need is
a Bricklink account
um that's it but very simple you know
just email password
[Music]
all right looking like the train is
winning right now
but that bridge y'all are the bridge is
coming up we'll give it a couple more
minutes not not a couple minutes that's
too long let's do the train guys let's
do the train
all right
so
how are we going to do this I'm gonna
bring in
scouty here and he's gonna help me
build this train okay so scouty I'm
gonna send you the password
on Discord
that's the password and I think this is
the ID I think
um
and let me go ahead and dock this for
you guys
yeah something like this
there we go
so scouty
um
if you go to Bricklink and you go to
build together you should be able to go
to join and you should type that stuff
in and and you should be able to just
drag bricks out and um
oh there you are yeah okay okay scouties
in sweet sweet all right so we got to
build this train let me send you the
reference
the reference image so you have this
um
yeah
there you go got you the reference on
Discord
um
all right so
I guess we have like a train car
and we have we have we have a front
train car a middle train car and a back
train car
and obviously this this thing is like
super blocky
um and we want to make it as small as
possible
with an inside of some sort still
because it would be cool to like shine a
light through the glass and have that
doing its thing so like
if we look at um
let me see if we look at like the shin
consent and how this train is done in
this book
we can look at some good reference
um
let's see
here we go
so in this book
basically
this is like one strip of the clear Lego
that acts as the window
so we're gonna have to figure this out
do this so if you search in the search
bar you can go um like three by
now let's go to plate all right we want
a plate
and we want a three
by
something maybe three by ten plate
and like the hardest thing is figuring
out
what to look for and what the name of
the piece is
yeah um oh maybe there's not a three by
ten maybe three by twelve
three by eight
is there no three by plate we can do
four by something
hmm
three by three perhaps
so we can we can bring out a couple of
these
and if I hold alt I can like kind of
duplicate as I go back
like this
right and even even like
this could be the the front train car
you know it could be that long or
something but feel um scouty feel free
to go through here and throw out any
pieces you think would work
for
um for this train
and then we can figure out we can kind
of like
assemble those pieces once we have some
pieces we think could work for this
thing
um
how is there not a three by
one good plate here
yeah I guess it doesn't go for I get
there's guess there's not like a Lego
piece that goes further than three by
three
but that's fine
that's fine
um window pieces so or brackets I feel
like uh
sweet yeah you can just throw it around
there throw it around the work area and
we'll we'll figure out
um
because I know
um there's like a window
a window piece
what was it called
um I swear it was like a bracket or
something
panel
yeah it was one of these guys
pretty sure
but I feel like you can go even smaller
with this thing
or is that as small as we're getting is
this guy right here
um if you want to rotate pieces it'll be
the arrow key so you select it arrow
keys will rotate and then you can move a
piece up and down left right with was
and D
um
three by three is tough the micro scale
thing is like it's difficult and yes
this is this is engineering now we are
Lego engineering guys
building out this Lego as efficiently as
possible
oh okay maybe we can use this piece
as
one of like the the chains of windows
because you see how like there's there's
like this long strip of window and then
there's this small window piece here
and it looks like there is
a window
a Long window and maybe two door windows
perhaps so we could do like um
search for Brick
and we could find a one by
I don't know a one by six and rotate it
around
uh
oh maybe a one by four or something
get that guy on top here
hmm
foreign
place and you can find pieces that are
similar this isn't giving us a
suggestion that we like but um so let's
take this to all pieces we can go back
to
panel we see if there's a longer yeah
there's one by four yeah so boom
replaced it with that and then we go
back to insert
right so we can make these different
colors so if I go up here and I type in
transparent transparent clear
right that'll be a window and then we
can go in here and we can color these
different ones like um
you know type in uh gray and we can do
a light bluish gray like that for this
piece I mean it looks like there's like
strips of orange down this thing we can
work that in later perhaps but for now
um I'm just going to select all these
with control and we can we can color
these the right the right color here I'm
going to select all this too you can
just drag Up drag a box around it
hitting wasd I'll hit s to just bring it
back down to the work plane
oh all right yeah I like I like these
pieces you're bringing out scouty these
are good
it's gonna help us with the front of the
train yeah if you want to if you want to
focus on like figuring out how the front
of the train would work I'll figure out
on like I'll figure out the body of the
train
hmm okay let's see this could be
um
we could go four wide but we can figure
that out in a minute I'm gonna try and
figure out the side of this thing
all right yeah okay let's do um
let's do like this like a 1x3 here
or maybe it's a one by two
two of these guys perhaps if you hold
alt it'll duplicate it
now we can do that on we can select both
of these and do that on the other side
and then perhaps
um
let's go one by
hmm
we can do a plate
on top of that one by five
Arrow key to
rotate one by six
maybe something like that and then
that'll give us kind of real estate to
to work the roof around
please
and maybe this piece can be that orange
piece that we saw in the reference
I don't like that orange
yeah maybe
one of these sure that's fine for now
maybe we go one more here
that way we have room for a door on both
sides
yeah
something like that so for the door
maybe what we could do so let's see how
it kind of like indents I'm wondering if
there's a way
is there a piece that does that I know
like these guys
these guys go in a little bit
right as you can see but as soon as you
put like a panel on top of that
you're kind of back out again
hmm
all right Nath let's let's see let's
check this ID
we got a piece suggestion
[Music]
dang this piece for what are you seeing
that for maybe the front or something
see that as like a front piece
whereas the top of the train Maybe
if you guys got suggestions feel free to
hop in with us
I see you all suggesting stuff in the
chat
um
if you want to join me brickling studio
is free you just make an account hop on
Discord DM me and um
and we'll see about getting you guys in
here
let's see um we got chicken NPC chilling
let's see if we can get another person
in here
um yes
all right my goal here is to get this
with this door going let's just
let's get a version in we can always
spice it up later okay so I'm gonna get
a brick
in here
um another brick
and let's see if that we just change
this to clear
transparent we'll get that grayed out
cool and then we will cap it off in the
back with a couple pieces here uh let's
see let's see
1 by 2
just like that
and then we have the front okay
so we'll do another one of these guys
we'll copy this over here
this orange piece definitely
we're gonna be able to extend this
further
so we'll go to Plate 1 by 12.
wouldn't be perfect but probably one by
eight or one by nine do they have a nine
one by eight should work
1 by 10
and we'll figure out we'll come back to
this because we're gonna figure out what
the heck we're doing up up on the front
side of things
[Music]
let me see if I can get this uh this
train lifted
there's some Underside business going on
and I think I have an idea for it so
let's try the brackets
and if we fit
let's see
yeah okay
so we can do stuff like this we'll flip
this around
and I'll throw a
tile on it tile piece the hardest part
again is learning the names of all these
pieces once you can kind of get through
that
then you're going to be working a lot
faster I promise
I know technically this is supposed to
be like
indented a little bit more into the
train
but again we'll get the V1 going and
then we'll go from there right so this
this piece we can probably just do as um
black and then this piece will do as a
dark gray
dark bluish Gray
yeah something like that
cool and I'm gonna duplicate this a
couple times
and I know there's some Wheels I know we
can get some Wheels going
[Music]
so let's check our wheel pieces let's
see what options we have for wheel
pieces and these got to be some tiny
Wheels here
so like here's some training business
but that's that's massive that's not
what we're going for we might have to
cheat the wheel
a little bit but we'll get there
uh this is this is closer to what we're
going for and this is supposed to be
underneath the Train the wheels are
definitely underneath the train so I
think the trick is trying to find uh
a wheel that stays underneath the train
and doesn't poke out
um I wonder
let's keep looking
let's keep
looking I wonder if there's like
single piece that the wheels can connect
to
oh here we go here we go this is
literally it this is it this is it I
know exactly how to do this
oh I like that piece
uh chicken are you in
so I'm gonna bring out a couple oh these
big how big are these things
here we go this one's a little smaller
I like that I like that
either one of these can be good but I
think this is the one
I think if we do
um I know exactly
sweet all right we got three people
building together right now we got
chicken and we got scouty
awesome
[Music]
let's do these as black okay so here
here's a here's an idea for the wheels
we could do like a little um
oh I like that piece I like that piece
so yeah I think right now
um
we have
scouty working on the front of the train
you guys can collaborate on that if you
want otherwise chicken if you want to
try working on the back of the train or
the roof perhaps
see about getting a roof piece going or
something that could be cool
um one thing about the front of the
train just make sure the windows here
they align they're on the same plane
right so technically
you know feel free to color your pieces
as you guys are going
um
uh what else here what else
yes all right so let's get this guy
snapped in I have an idea for this one
so I believe it will be a modified
a modified plate I think
modified plate yes yes we we need these
little this like hook piece
hmm
how are we going to do this I need to
attach this to the bottom
the train
and it's cool because there's so many
different ways
to go about building these Legos
there's a piece I'm looking for
um if you hover over these pieces here
like I want one with the hook
with u-clip okay so if I type in u-clip
we get all these different ones and I
want one facing up like this like this
facing up
maybe this is the one here it's
basically I'll flip this like that boom
right see how it's connected and then I
just gotta connect that to the bottom of
this thing
and I think I can do that with like a
hmm
foreign
basically need
the smallest possible attachment
we could do a plate round maybe in here
that needs to go
underneath
that will go underneath yes that would
this will go underneath
so let's select these guys
there we go
yo that works that totally works that
totally totally works
yes
color this black
that's perfect
perfect perfect
I like that all right cool
foreign
so
I'll keep saying this because
you know it's fun basically we're all
building together I have two other
people here we got scouting and we got
chicken
NPC up in here we're building together
we're building this train
um
if you guys want to join me of course
brickling Studios the program we're
working in got it linked below you just
need to make an account
um it's free
it's not a sponsored video I'm just
having fun here and um
you guys can hop in hit me up on Discord
that's where we're doing this on Discord
is where I'm going to give you the
password okay
um I know there's a few steps we're
going through
certainly but uh
yeah I don't want to just blast the
blast the password into the into the
chat here into the live chat because who
knows what Madness will ensue
I think we can delete this guy we don't
need that
I'm gonna work on
the bottom of this guy
whoa
oh I need the uh
technically there is clipping and you
can turn off
clipping or turn on clipping
with this little Collision button and
that'll make sure that it won't it won't
let you do that it won't let you clip
but I might
need to
and God dang it
oh I wonder okay this gives me an idea I
wonder if there is a piece
like this that goes on both sides so you
can hit replace and go to suggested and
see what they have
and it looks like they have
um
they have a longer one we don't want
that to undo that
and this is a bracket so
[Music]
oh do they have one that goes on both
sides what is this piece
interesting
what's up chilling Dylan
how you chilling this morning
so we can group this right I can select
all this create a sub model and I'll
just call this wheel
and now it's just one piece right so we
can
drag this out
I can get this right
there it is that's the attachment right
there it's a little it's a little long
I feel like we can do better but for now
I'm Gonna Leave it okay
that beat there's God
away
there's got to be a way let's release it
and let's see if there's a replacement
no okay it's a one by piece
um
what is like the smallest
piece
hmm
I know there was like little connector
pieces or if there's like step down
pieces or something
so you have all these color options here
and if you don't want that you can hit
this little Lego head icon and that will
just
kind of clean up the the library here so
that you can search a little bit more
efficiently
you don't need to see every
iteration of every piece you just need
to see the one piece you know every
individual piece here
so I'm trying to find like a little step
down piece
to hook these wheels up to the bottom of
this thing
as efficiently as possible
and who knows maybe there's one I don't
know it might be a technic piece
for all we know
oh I like that roof panel it's so this
might be a situation chicken where we
have to do uh yeah four wide
because I think that piece could be cool
unless you do something like
um
because it has those middle pieces in
there
get like
a middle strip going
there might be something you could use
if you could do a single slope piece
but let's see if I can't figure out this
uh
connector
hmm
foreign
something like
something like this
oh these are cool pieces
I wonder if that could be used for
something on the side of the train
perhaps
foreign
it's hard making these like mini Legos
because you really just need to find the
right pieces
but it's very fun
these could be good too
for the windows
oh wow that's literally that's just
that's just the subway like
window that's incredible
we got Lego ladders okay interesting
could be a track
dude don't tell me this actually fits on
this thing
foreign
it's crazy so these actually Bend I'll
show you this
you can bring this out
select uh the bend option you could take
this piece
be able to
[Music]
come on now
nothing to insert it into
ah I guess I don't have the right pieces
to insert into but you get the idea
right this can
orbit around like that is pretty cool
um I'm still trying to find a piece to
connect this dang wheel to the bottom of
this thing with
that could actually work
this if this will actually uh
fit underneath the the train
which
yeah it could go in there but I need it
to be symmetrical
I would essentially need
okay that works I gotta turn Collision
back on
see if this actually fits in here
in here let's go with a plate
wait a second
oh that was longer my goodness if that
was longer
thank you
foreign
oh I got signed out
I lost my builders
let's sign back in
all right Builders we're back
scouty chicken
um let's uh
okay yeah I'm Still Still streaming that
cool
thank you
so let's see maybe we can do one of
these guys in the middle this guy goes
in
to that
come on now sometimes it's difficult to
to like line up these pieces I'm not
gonna lie
but you can click it and um move it
around this way as well
wasd
there we go see that's way low that's
still like way lower than what I want
maybe we can turn off the grid
or turn off snapping
somehow they're still snapping
okay that works
and we can throw some wheels on there
that maybe the Technic pieces
Technic
um
what is that I know the piece
here we go this one right here
oh I see so that's gonna be hmm
what the heck
snapping should not be on I don't know
why it's on
there we go so I changed the grid to
like
finer finer snaps and then I think that
works
cool
I think you can select a piece and hit
um
copy and mirror and it'll uh
go over to the other side I'm just
hitting that D key to get that over so
it's not far off from this one but
honestly it is a little bit more tucked
up
in which I'm a fan of
all right let's see um scouty are you
still with us
I might have to
let's see let's do the bottom of this
train
organize our pieces and then I'll
probably hop onto the front of this
thing
all right what's this good piece for
entertainment you can put it in the
middle of a three by three plate
[Music]
let's see uh two six five five attaches
to the wheels
let's find out
so you can type in the part ID as well
oh
that is the one
that is the one all right let's get
snapping back on
Collision we can do it legit This Time
Boom
that's what I'm talking about
let's get this wheel back snap that
right oh
dude
look at that look at that no
scary times scary times
but that's the move thank you my
goodness Mr for entertainment that is
the move
all right let me let me close this um
let me close this down and let's reboot
um
for you guys let's host it and see
if that works
cool cool cool
all right so I don't technically I don't
know what a train
wheel is supposed to look like I'm gonna
look this up real quick um
[Music]
where are the wheels located on this
thing
here we go there's like a nice side view
so it has like
two wheels in the front maybe two wheels
on the back
and the wheels are kind of connected
okay got you all right
I am
sweet I wonder if they have like a three
by of this one here also I need to get
it onto the other side I feel like
maybe we should commit
to
the four
plate version of this
and see if that
is possible
let's give it a shot so I'm gonna grab
this three by replace it
with a 4x4
X4 plate oh come on now
um turn up hiding stuff no I shouldn't
be doing that
is going to be your select tool we want
to replace that with the 4x4 plate
boom
there we go
let's see if we can't uh
reconfigure this over here
you can just select everything I'll drag
it over
all right guys we got the new train on
the
foreign
the old train
see if I can't turn off this grid
hide the ground there we go yeah makes
it a little easier
sweet and then I think that'll actually
allow us to to use this
two times
here
yep and I I'm hoping I'm pretty sure I
can scoot this over
um
okay so to figure that out
unless this just goes
over like that
yeah that could work for now
I have an idea for these
bottom bits here I think we can do uh
let's see what's going on with this
plate
right here
um all right let's try and grab like the
lantern piece
all right
um
bum
[Music]
I feel like there was a bigger wheel
and this guy is probably oh skateboard
okay
I feel like there was one
uh a wheel that was a little bit larger
than this guy
yeah was it this guy
yes just a touch larger
God dang it come on now
that that that's the most frustrating
part about this program is like
trying to
pieces to connect all right so that
won't connect to that
I think that's fine I think we're good
like this
let's maybe grab a little uh
slope piece
or maybe it's this angled tile
here we go yeah this guy
and we can copy and mirror
bam
I feel like technically these guys need
to be one pushed one back
so I wonder if I can
back one
yeah
this guy moved back this guy moves back
all these guys move
back
that's just kind of like tucked in a
little bit more
like that maybe
also the front of the train can totally
be the back of the train too
nice yeah that roof piece is cool
foreign
like this roof would probably have to
end um let's see slope curved
curved
yeah one of these guys
probably
okay yeah so we'll do um
let's see all right so we could yeah we
could do
maybe just another
okay yeah I'll do two by two
one by two
there it is
yeah and then we'll do the we'll do
let's see uh
plate there's like an angled plate
this guy
and copy and mirror
did it over there which is weird
hit that with the orange
oh we could probably slip something in
the front there
could just be another
plate here
it's fun
yeah
we gotta get some lights on this thing
it's the lantern pieces the lantern
pieces
foreign
pop up here
here
and you can just hit it with a
yeah one of these guys
boom boom
then we can do translucent
Orange
or red actually I think
yeah
that's cool
[Music]
that's super fun
I like that
[Music]
I wonder if we can maybe replace this
piece with say a bracket
and maybe maybe what we do is we replace
this with a
a one by one
the one by version
um let's see
because it'd be cool to have like
a little um a little readout for like
where the train is going
on the front you know
it looks like you guys are
glitching here
I'm gonna
cut the
the collab build here for a second
wrap this train out
T let's see let's see
feeling like we can do one of these
slope pieces the one by piece yeah
here
boom
you can copy mirror should go over yeah
nice
gray those out
and then
foreign
[Music]
let's try a bracket piece
oh my goodness this is totally gonna
work
wow
because then these guys can just
go here
we can go back to that two piece
because it's cleaner
awesome awesome awesome
and then we just hit this with like a
tile
1x4 tile but we actually we turned these
on
so we can see if there are like
certain tiles here that could work for
us
in terms of like
[Music]
so we do one by two tile
and is there like one with text or
something
and
um is it Japanese something or
Chinese
address
okay there's a letter
um
maybe we just scroll through these and
see what we find
[Music]
foreign
could work
this one maybe
ah yeah okay
let's try it
now
this totally works though
that's awesome
I love it I love it I love it
it's a little um
feels like it's got a giant forehead
and I don't think that works I don't
think that works
if there was
how would you insert that into there
like that's a tough one
[Music]
um
you'd really have to like
you know for now I'm Gonna Leave It
because I think this looks great
these are a little low
so I'm wondering if potentially
is there a way to like
them like this grab this guy flip them
around
we should be able to get this guy up in
here
uh yeah I feel like
that should be
proper right there
all right on tech let's see uh there's a
one by one plate
actually
these have little things on them I could
pop that in there
all right one by one plate with a
downward side stud
if you have a part number
help me
oh we got wind Bush up in here and Ronin
and Melanie my goodness wow geez
everyone's up in here
ah good to see everybody
it's been a long time
yeah Ronan this software is incredible
man it's the best it's really really fun
um really really easy to use pretty
straightforward
Winbush so you worked on Lego Batman and
Lego Harry Potter back in the day and
still got the character models if you
want them for the scene oh nice dude
that's awesome did you wind Bush have
you ever used this program
I just stumbled on it I was looking for
programs I know there's a couple of them
but um
this one this one's pretty sweet I
really really enjoy it
um
the fact that you can like export to
uh
you know I can show you guys the process
too let me wrap this train out and I'm
gonna show you how it works
it's perfect that's wonderful yeah it
would be nice to get one more of these
over here
maybe just a one piece
um
let's go for that bracket I'll get this
locked in
yeah wind bush is great it's called um
Bricklink brickling studio
um
if you want to hop in and build with me
you're welcome to there's like a collab
build thing
um you just make an account
it's not sponsored or anything I'm just
having fun with it
yeah Mega bricks that's the other one
it's browser-based
[Music]
all right Alex let's try this part
number okay
that's so funny dude that's what I was
going for
wow
if there's like a corner version of this
because yeah basically I get that
um
I'll grab a one by one tile
pop that there color it
basically like that
see these like angled bracket pieces
just trying to lock in this front bit
I think we're locked
[Music]
and like this maybe or
for sure Winbush we'll get it we'll get
it man
[Music]
let's see Alex
you got the part numbers for me I
appreciate that okay you said just use
that on one of these
wait that's the same number
uh Alex I think that's the same number
you just pasted
uh I need like an angled
bracket one piece thing
one on top of the other
it's a bit low though
uh unless
no can I I can't flip it
like that technically doesn't work
I wish it did
um
Alex are you on Discord do you have this
downloaded you should uh you should hop
in with me I'd love to see what you mean
what up wondrous
yup that's it thank you thank you thank
you
that's pretty sweet
that's pretty sweet I like that
thank you
foreign
one of these guys a shorty version
huh
that's the shorty version
but it doesn't have the pieces I need
it's like giant fog horn thing
I think this totally works for now
though
it's pretty sweet
let's go ahead and copy a mirror
move this over
bam
and maybe there's a
okay I'm thinking about 1 by 2 plate
modified
uh where is it
one with a little hook on it
that like Central Little Hook piece
where are you
enjoy yourself
it is a modified plate yeah it's this
piece
I just don't know if it's necessary
though
do
uh
foreign
this guy right so this connects to the
other trains in the back
so
do I have room
don't have room
unless
nah because this all needs to be flat
still pretty flat but dang it the Lego
police are on me
dude
yeah that I ain't I don't think I'm
gonna do that
laughs
unless I add like one more like a like a
four by five doesn't even have a four by
five plate
I don't think so
oh you know what okay okay okay okay
two bracket here
come on now
uh maybe one of
these guys
dude come on why
why
[Music]
I know technically I don't need to be
doing it this legit
but it's fun I don't know this is cool
I like this let's color this up
[Music]
sweet
that is uh
that is a train
a back window
get that
ah if we had one more
I know it's possible I know it's
possible
let me see let me see here
um
that's the piece we want
modified plate all right I'm gonna lock
this in here
and then I should probably move on I'll
show you guys how to export this
to c4d and then we can move on to the
weekly challenge and I'll announce the
winners and I'm gonna call it because
it was a busy week filmed a really cool
video this week I think you guys are
gonna like it it's not gonna come out
for a little bit but um it's a very fun
one it has to do with some photo
scanning
um
yeah and I got I got a fun
fun little video for you guys in July as
well
um halfway through July
otherwise you know we we'll catch up
here we'll catch up let me wrap this up
and we'll catch up so
let's see uh let's do a
modified plate
I'll grab that guy
four by six
four by six plate right
there we go so let me see if I can use
this
get rid of that
all right get that guy in there
[Music]
as far as the reference goes
um
yeah here's what I could do I could take
all of this
and move all of this over by two
foreign
wasd to move these around
and then
all essentially I'll just grab this guy
pop one right in there
and we'll
do that again
we'll glass this guy
is gray
put that in there cool
and then I think I'll just I'll probably
do this as a full
yeah just like that
that feels better to me
that's awesome
that way we can have a little bit more
roof detail which I'm a fan of
and I feel like there's got to be a
piece in here a slope piece
um
that allows us to have something in the
middle
right like this wait not like this this
is huge like this but um
way smaller
hmm
okay
I guess like this but the inverse
maybe it's a I don't know a wedge sorry
a slope or something
now it's not in here
yeah I think uh I think we should
definitely do a Lego themed weekly
challenge I agree with you
that would be incredible
Lego world and build out your coolest
coolest Lego world
we'll put that right on the end there
I guess that will go into that so I
would need two what
two brackets worth
or like a bracket and a half it's a
little confusing I could just copy this
whole thing over and I'm probably just
going to do that yes
yeah let's copy all of this
over
copy and mirror
we'll drag it on over
just get on the ground that's the heart
that's the worst part about this program
is just
how annoying it is
Place stuff
is that it did I nail it ah
close
all right close but we can dial it in
with was and D
udge it over there we go and then push
it back by one yep and replace this you
can go to replace bam with that
but I feel like it needs to be out a
little bit more so maybe
take all this and
foreign
guys
goodness gracious
hey
come on now how's that
there we go
can I sneak another one of these in
I think I can amazing
awesome awesome awesome
yeah that way they they connect and
we can close this up
so we'll do this with one of these we'll
raise it up I believe this was a l piece
yep
get that in there duplicate this hold
alt flip it around with the arrow keys
get it in place
and we'll close it up with a 1 by 2
plate
make sure we're in insert mode
we want yeah one by two plate
and I'll export this for you guys
technically this is a door right here so
basically get it in like that perfect
that's it guys
that's awesome
[Music]
sweet
alright so if I want to export this
right
all you need to do is go to file
export as colada file collater file
right you can choose to include the Lego
logos on it
um I don't
yeah call this train
and let's open up c4d
and I'll show you what it looks like
real quick
I'll show you how cool it can be
and then we'll hop into that weekly
challenge y'all
okay
so basically when you import collata
files into c4d
it's jacked up all right it's just it's
just jacked up I'll show you what I mean
and I'll show you what you got to do
to fix it so when you import it
basically uh let's see let's see let's
see assets no
yeah okay
that's saved here I believe
train
palatophile I bring it in it opens the
colada 1.4 import settings
um these settings should be correct I'll
hit OK and it just brings in the
materials that's it that's not what we
want obviously not right so here's how
you fix it I have a download link in the
description for you it leads to a really
old
fbx converter
all right it's the
Autodesk fbx converter you're gonna
download the the 20 it's 2013
64. I have the version number for you
2013.2 that's also in the description
download the 2013.2 version and it's so
easy all you do
is you drag the colada file
in
and you just hit convert
that's it
you see bam made it fbx done drag the
fbx in
and look at that
we got a trained
all right now let's get the scale right
so I'm going to make a figure
the figure somewhere in that train or
unless we're like
astronomical scale here
I'll have to like relearn these hotkeys
all right boom
um we can delete this the model Let's uh
let's get this correct so the Axis
Center tool
Point Center include all children nope
let's not do that
dude what
what Droid let's try it again
I'm gonna try it one more time if I
screw this up
execute okay it's not doing it
so we'll hit l
put our coordinates here
flip this 180.
and
Center this up
manually
hitting l
will bring up the Axis tool
pressing s is going to snap your
viewport to what you have selected
middle Mouse click in your windows will
actually
pop you
um in and out of
these like four panel View and if you
want to hop into the perspective you
just Mouse over middle click and and
you're in
so we'll zero this out
reset transformation let's bring that
figure back in
it's way too big
so I'm just going to scale the model
down to what I think would be Lego brick
size
I'm not trying to be like super accurate
with it God dang it come on
something like that
maybe a little smaller I don't know you
can delete the figure
and I'm gonna show you how I get this
set up in octane so let's go ahead and
save this
uh
cool um so octane right let me go ahead
and dock this these little like these
three horizontal lines I can click and
drag those
load my scene
all right so we um
it's it's bringing this in as a bunch of
instances and it actually it looks like
this one is flipped around the wrong way
just interesting because
that's never done that to me before but
that's okay
I'll click that
let's just do a little 180 on this guy
maybe it was that way in uh
Studio
but that's all right
let's um let's make things look a little
nice first all right
um materials we're going to convert the
materials it's going to convert well I
guess you gotta select them first
materials
convert materials we'll go Octane and
then I'll just do materials uh remove
unused and that'll keep it as octane uh
I'm gonna make a quick plane real quick
uh yeah that's fine and set up
and hdri
we're gonna make a HDR environment
octane Sky you can do materials or
rather objects HDR environment
you can load whatever one you want in
here but I use uh the hdri link from
grayscale gorilla if you go to the
environment tag you can drag the texture
channel here into the environment tag
and then when you click on the
environment tag you can open the
grayscale gorilla plus Library hop into
here and we can choose whatever ones we
want
um I made these hdris
are they in here
drop them in here
hdri I mean at night it's probably not
personal yes I did so I made these hdris
in uh
in Shinjuku and golden guy
right and they're these like night
Street hdri
environments they're on my patreon I
have a whole post about my my Japan trip
and uh I guess what I would call them
creative recovery and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about that right now because
um I was not in a good place
last year
changes to linear
see is this looking is this hdri working
our
rent let's get the uh
let's go into the model
and let's adjust these materials so
let's go to roughness we want to take
the roughness to like point
o one or something
specular will take up to one
just gotta do a little bit of work on
the materials that's all
um next I'm going to make a translucent
material this clear one
yeah let's set this guy up this should
be this should be correct here
um instead of glossy we want it to be
specular
and I'm I'm actually going to do a
little round edges so I'm going to grab
all these and we're going to check round
edges I think my face is probably
blocking it but if you go to the basic
little
um tab here you can click round edges
and that'll add around edges for all of
the materials you have selected we'll
create round edges and we'll go in here
I'm going to change this to accurate and
the the roundness or the radius will do
um
0.5 of it whoa
0.25
even 0.15
.1 even you know something that that
feels right
for you guys
um let's switch up our hdri see if we
can find something a little bit better
just going through some of my hdri packs
here
[Music]
these are this is my abandoned hdri pack
I don't know if I've uploaded this to be
honest
I'm gonna do let's see for this clear
let's try going to the common
I think fake Shadows that might help
this like see-through
look just a little bit obviously we have
too many
um
instances Swap this let's try and get
this with
um
hmm
I have to go through all these and make
these editable
so if you actually so I learned to say
that if you select this object here in
the viewport and then you Mouse over to
the objects window you hit s and it's
going to find
that piece
and they essentially just I'm gonna go
through and
re-texture that honestly you can just
drag it onto the piece that's a lot
easier isn't it
and I'm hitting C to make these editable
they're all instances
find that
looks like for some reason it's
not liking that
but we'll get there
these guys are all transparent yes
these guys are transparent too so I'm
gonna take that transparent red
and we're going to also change it to a
specular material
let's go opacity you know I'm gonna
let's see if I just make a new one
if it looks a bit more
erect no it's the same okay that's fine
specular cool and then let's do
um the transmission
color we'll get this tinted red
and it looks like it's still not working
I'm gonna set it to the comma and we'll
set the fake Shadows on
yeah they're working
they're just very reflective
there we go so I set the index to 1.1
and that looks
that looks a little bit better we can go
1.01
probably a little much huh 1.1 looks
nice and uh it's too red
so we'll go to the transmission and just
take that down
something like that
foreign
I think we can do that same like
reflectivity thing with the uh the other
clear guys so I'll take the index to 1.1
as well
oh my goodness path tracing that's why
yeah that looks so much better
and for our plane we can even throw
let's see well here let me finish doing
all the
materials
this is making no sense to me I don't
know why
I guess that's because that is the
they're all being instanced off of that
but it's fine I guess I'll just
adjust it
for all of these
which is quite a pain to be honest
dude what uh
jeez
I don't know why it didn't transfer over
correctly
but you know yeah
you roll with the punches you know
that's close enough
that is close enough
there we go
sweet
and I still want to get
let's do a camera let's make a camera
imager will adjust the exposure a little
bit
keep your eyes here
that's fun
[Music]
oh these Studio ones look nice
I like that you can grab the plane
as well
maybe give it a dark
black
did you depth of field going you know
like there's a there's a whole lot you
can do here A whole lot you can do
surface imperfections all that good
stuff
so that's um yeah that's that's the Lego
workflow that I've been messing with and
having fun with and I'm gonna put a
whole video out at some point when it's
done
it'll be done at some point I don't know
when it'll be done but I'm working on a
big video
um with all of this stuff so I have a
ton of locations that I want to build
out and put together like a
yeah something cool for you guys
something sweet I'm excited about it but
um let's go ahead and hop in to
let me switch over here
be challenged because the theme we had a
theme it was a colossal I believe I
believe or was that last
now it was memory memory is this one
that we're talking about today
um
so you know there's a few winners as you
do
um we'll get through the weekly winners
and then I'm going to hang out with you
guys for maybe 10-15 minutes and just
chat
catch up on
you know how the last few months have
been what I've been up to chat with you
guys
um
yeah and we'll get into it
all right so
um
yeah let's do let's hop into it let's
hop over to the weekly side of things
all right let me full screen this guy
here so I can see
what's going on yes all right
so
let's begin
we're gonna go with the winners and then
we're gonna get into the honorable
mentions so the theme was memory or
memories
um and our first winner is Jack the hack
with this beautiful piece I love this so
much
um obviously all of this stuff is very
subjective right this one really spoke
to me just because it felt like an old
film photo that I would have taken
um on a trip he said that he took this
on a trip in I believe Italy or
something I may got the place make it
the place wrong but it's based off an
old photo that he took from uh
from a trip that he went on and I just
love that lighting it's like
middle of the day
um
I don't know if it really truly does
feel like a memory it feels like an old
film photo and I just love it so
congratulations Jack the hector you got
15 points towards your rank on the
server
um next up we have La gracious
hahaha
there is a few of these
um or there were a few of these rather
you know uh about video games and TVs
and whatnot
um and there are some good ones out
there and you might see one or two in
the honorable mentions but this one of
course spoke to me the most because I
was a PlayStation guy
um grew up on PlayStation I see you know
I'm gonna show you some stuff check it
out
check it out
now I'm not gonna dig all the way into
it but uh
I see you got Metal Gear Solid down
there
it's one of my favorite games of all
time
um I actually picked this one up in
Japan
Tekken 3 all in Japanese
I'm I'm loving it uh I got some Crash
Bandicoot and some Spyro down there too
uh some crash team racing I see you got
in your drawer here in your render I
love it so much and this one really
spoke to me because it did remind me of
going to my grandpa's place and uh we
would bring the PS1 because I was like
there's nothing to do with my grandpa's
place
except mow the lawn I feel like we
always we were just always mowing the
lawn perpetually at my grandpa's place I
was like you know what I'm bringing the
PS1 this time I'm bringing crash team
racing
um I'm bringing crash bash
and we would just this was like this is
crazy actually this is right when the
internet was a thing
and we would go on to the dial-up
internet uh his dial up internet
and download we would go to uh
supercheats.com and we would
print out just like pages and pages of
cheat codes for Crash Bandicoot
um and it was the best
the PlayStation in the TV was like set
up in our room right next to the pull
out couch so I see you have like the
covers here it's right next to a bed of
some sort
um dude that this is great this one this
one I loved uh so congratulations
scouty you're next Bud
um you have to move with me we built
Legos together and you're winning the
weekly challenge
I love this man beautiful environment
love the center framing love the
lighting love the composition
um we're re-watching uh avatar Last
Airbender and the wangshi tongs
librarian season two was like one of my
favorite episodes it's creepy it's super
cool it's like very uh adventurous and I
totally get those vibes from from this
right here
um takes me back to one of my favorite
games of all time hyper light Drifter
where there is a big old massive library
in that game as well and I wonder if
they did reference it from Avatar I
wonder
but yeah I don't know man massive
libraries is super cool feels very
dreamy as well like you don't know if
it's reality or not
but uh I would love to be in this place
I think it's cool congrats congrats uh
scouty on the win 15 points towards your
rank next up we got tubby buddy
with this one yeah this is a cool little
like uh like advertisement of some sort
um looks like a show or something or
an ad you would see on the side of the
street but I love I love this I love the
lighting I love that you took a
different approach to it
um and this whole like
fluid Sim you have in the brain coming
out it's super cool I love it I love
your lighting I love your colors
um cool pose too big fan congrats tubby
buddy and finally finally we have uh we
have under
with this one and this is disgusting
this is gross this totally reminds me of
uh there's a silent hill game maybe it's
Silent Hill too I don't know uh it feels
very silent hillish but there's a hole
in her face and it's like leaking and
spilling out into the floor that is
disgusting
um
not good not good she's had some bad
memories all right also the table
classic man reminds me of uh quixel
bridge I remember I remember using
quixel Bridge
back in the day
I'm just kidding I I use it a lot
um but congrats under good stuff uh we
have a few honorable mentions right just
because
um
you know you didn't win doesn't mean
your art was cool and it didn't speak to
me so I want to shout out some people
each one of these guys gets Five Points
towards their rank on the server and of
course if you participated in the weekly
challenge you get one point and we level
up we level up on the Discord server
links down below if you guys want to
participate in these things we'll do a
Lego one
I mean as soon as we can do the next one
we do them every week we're doing a Lego
one all right
um because it's a blast right but
honorable mentions first off we got Bean
whipped
now this one's special okay usually we
we just keep it to 3D renders only all
right
but um being whipped he had some uh
family members pass away we got his two
uncles on the left here and his twin
brother on the right and um he drew them
in memory of them and I thought you know
we should we should shout him out here
um on the live stream and and just uh
just pay our respects because clearly he
loved him you know he this is an amazing
picture he put together incredible
detail incredible work and uh I'm sorry
for your loss and I hope um
yeah it's it's I'm it's one of the
toughest things to go through losing a
loved one so
um you know shout outs to them they seem
like cool dudes
um next up we have can Syrian
and this is what I was talking about
this was talking about the other one and
I and technically I like the lighting a
little bit better in this one I think
the there there's a little bit more
details but again the other one spoke
spoke to me a little bit more not to say
that this one is better or worse I love
it that's all I'm trying to say is I
love it
um
really great render quality awesome
lighting
uh really nice models you have here good
setup it's tough to recreate a messy
room and you did a good job here so I I
wanted to shout you out there
oh we got Ina next
um this one I love this one
it's stylized I love the colors like you
the colors you chose here were very very
deliberate and I think you did a solid
job another
um great example of a messy room it
actually looks messy and I just love
those pastels and feels so soft and like
a commercial or something yeah it's a
cool look it's a really really cool look
next we have Frodo
um this one is great I you know as often
as I could I would go Urban exploring
uh with friends a lot with with my buddy
Brett
and this was when we were in Atlanta
and Atlanta is an old city right and
there's a lot of old abandoned buildings
and we would go around and we would
explore and take photos and dress up in
costumes and film little videos and
it really brought me back to that time
and this Lighting in particular is very
dreamy to me
um I don't know why this overcast not
overcast but golden hour lighting is is
so dreamy
but
I don't know when you think of some old
past memory
golden hour you know that it's uh that's
the lighting that kind of pops up in my
head at least maybe this is just me but
feels like a dream it really does feel
like a dream and I think Inception
probably did a good job kind of
burrowing that into my mind because
I remember that like Cafe scene
when everyone looked at uh at um at Leo
and I think it was a go it was a weird
orange golden hour vibe there too
um and it was dreamy it was a dream I
think
um yeah that's weird weird how that
works next up we have sci-fi I guess is
their name
um this is super cool I love it love the
detail love the colors the composition
the render quality is all there for me
um again huge gamer so
I thought this one was really cool
really awesome I didn't want to shout
you out as well a voice of fear is next
um this one is really sweet I like this
angle I like the the wide angle lens I
like your color I like your composition
two notes for you though one
you have some cards some floating cards
up on the ceiling you definitely want to
uh fix that get your Textures in there
second
um this giant space on the left this
dark space on the left uh I feel like
it's blocking a lot of the image and it
really is um I think clashing with the
the focal point
which is the character I think if you
would have pushed that that giant block
further out to the right and move the
character and the vocal point out to the
right kind of done a weird off-center
kind of thing I think that could have
been cool but it's just off balance for
me it's out of balance so I would I
would either take that drawer and push
it back a little further
um but otherwise I love your color I
love your scene uh I love your
composition and I think just those
couple things could help you
um
this other one is called you became
nothing but a memory so I don't know who
this is that's why it's important to
name your stuff
pour it into name
your file
um as your Discord name that way I can
shout you out and that way you can get
your points okay
you don't want to miss out I thought
this was a super cool idea
um
you know
yeah the textures could have been you
know up here or there but whatever
I just thought the idea was super cool
cool enough that I that I had to shout
you out I thought it was pretty darn
unique
um
you know cluttered mind kind of a thing
uh but also it's very artsy it's very
beautiful looking
so in this person's mind they have a lot
of good memories perhaps
but I love it I love that texture I love
like the the actual texture like how it
feels
um the way it's broken up with all this
coming out the back of his head here
um the the room I feel like yeah I don't
know what that floor is I don't know if
that's like
untextured something something looks
like the walls are made of marble looks
like he's made of marble maybe but I
don't know what the floor is made out of
um
some crown molding could help you on the
bottom some trim can really help you as
well uh maybe a tile floor black tile
floor reflective black tile floor I
think would actually be sick with uh
with all that
Greenery coming out the back of this
character's head I think would look sick
is that it I think that's it guys
congratulations to the winners congrats
to the honorable mentions and if if you
participated even congratulations to you
as well
um
you know uh we do these every week once
again we got the Discord link for you
down in the description if you want to
join us on these weekly challenges
please uh it's free to hop in
and it's a good time it's a great way to
practice your craft and hang out
um and when I stream we do these usually
uh I'll just do a little little video
um for the weekly challenge every week
to shout out the winners but yeah it's
fun to do it on the Stream
so
and for the next 15 minutes with you
guys hanging out we'll talk about
whatever
um so hit me with questions if you guys
have any questions
man I get a haircut today I am
so excited
so excited for this haircut it's been
too long I wear this hat like every day
pretty much wear the same clothes every
day guys I got the same three four pairs
of pants of different colors I got the
same I mean t-shirts basically
um and this darn hat I love this hat
but uh the main reason I wear it is
because I'm lazy and I don't want to do
my hair and my hair doesn't look good
that's why I do it
wait look at this
oh
boy
oh boy
um so I get a haircut today five o'clock
very excited about that
I'm very excited about that
hit me with the questions y'all at
Punisher in the chat
um I'll hang out for the next 15
I went to Japan we got back two weeks
ago
um my goodness was that the best I love
Japan I've been there it was my third
trip
this time around and um
I was actually able to use the language
because I've been studying for the last
three years and I finally was able to
use it every single day
and it felt like I had learned an
instrument and never was it never able
to play it until
you know two weeks ago
so that was cool
it was really cool it was definitely
like Elementary level
uh language skills here but I was able
to chat with locals and ask a bunch of
questions and get around it was fun
it was very fun and very peaceful my
goodness you guys know I don't know if
you followed me at Corridor or whatever
you guys know I'm all about taking
breaks
chilling out and taking the time
necessary to recover because we can't
just work work all day and I learned
that lesson every year I burnt out the
first year
um I I kind of rebooted my YouTube
channel and that was rough and I made a
video I called it uh we can't live off
of snacks that was the name of the video
and
I talk about how I'm I'm burning out I
gotta slow down I gotta post less
I thought posting less was the answer
and I was kind of I was kind of getting
there I was kind of getting towards what
I what ultimately was
the the the right answer for me
um at the time it was post less and work
on larger projects that I'm really
passionate about and I was I was getting
onto something I was onto something
but the next year this is last year okay
we're halfway through we're in June now
but last year uh come the end of the
year I burnt out again a second time and
I'm like man why did I burn out again
this is really weird I thought that I
did everything I had to do I thought I'd
posting less and working on the passion
projects was helpful and yes it was
helpful but
why why did I burn out again it's rough
um
oh wonders you're getting a haircut too
that's awesome dude heck yeah
that's great
and I I was like what the heck man and
maybe I already talked about this on the
stream I feel like I've talked about
this a bunch of times with friends uh
but um
yeah the artist's way and uh the
creative act I did talk about this on
the stream I read those two books and
man that opened my eyes to to so much I
didn't realize that I had an unhealthy
approach to to creating
and honestly a lot of it has to do with
YouTube it's really annoying it sucks
how that works out right but YouTube is
constantly like they're gonna let you
know as soon as your video doesn't do as
well like it puts you it ranks you
immediately and that is not good for
creativity and it's it it makes it a
competition
not just with yourself but with the
algorithm with everyone else and I I
realized it is like running a YouTube
channel
is not the most conducive and healthy
way to be creative
um
but that can that could be said for any
like let's say take a musician for
example and they're they're you know
working on albums and
um releasing albums to the world and
let's say an album blows up
right
uh it does really well they're gonna
feel pressure like I feel pressure to
continue doing what other people love
and
that's real tricky that is really really
tricky you start chasing what you think
other people want you to do and because
it's worked in the past right
um and you start going down a path that
is not your path
and it and it might be someone else's
path or your idea of someone else's idea
of what you think
would be cool it's it's messed up
you can't create that way you you really
have to focus on what you think is cool
and I think if you listen to that
this is what I'm learning right now this
is what I'm trying to trying to to
practice here if I can really hone in on
what I think is cool not what I think
other people want me to make
that's the best way to create
um really it's the only way to create
um it's not to get views it's not to
make a living it's not to make money
it's not to
um uh to get popular
it all it's not even to make
masterpieces like the best thing like
obviously that is that is the goal you
want to do that
but you have to be okay with making
stuff that's not good as well and I
think
it I want to put out the most polished
stuff possible on my YouTube channel
everything I do wherever whatever I post
you know whatever I create I want it to
be the best it can be and um
you know you set such a high standard I
set such a high standard for myself that
it's hard to like top it it's hard to
beat it and I think just that mindset
alone is
is tricky it's very tricky I'm actively
kind of shutting myself down like oh
that idea is not good enough because of
X Y and Z I'm not even gonna do it
but no I think being as open and as free
as possible to make whatever you want
without rules without
um anyone's input
what's the best thing I think I could
make and and and that's been my goal
here and understanding that
it's okay if I don't post every two
weeks or month even
um
it's more important that I'm just as
healthy as possible creatively and just
as a person too because I think they go
hand in hand being a person living life
and being creative for me is the same
thing
um so
you know the healthier the healthier I
am the healthier you guys are to
yourself the better
better art you're gonna make
um you don't have to follow Trends just
stick to what you love and there's going
to be people who are going to love what
you love too
and I'm learning this
and I'm trying to be okay oh I didn't
post on this day
you know I hadn't streamed in a long
time
I I I kind of need to not worry about
that you know
um
and now with that being said with all
that being said this year has been one
of been one of the best years creatively
and life-wise because again they're the
same for me
um you know in a while since I started
my YouTube channel I think since the
maybe the very beginning it reminds me
of right when I rebooted my channel
um uh three years ago
and
I had so much stuff that I was excited
to put out and I feel like that's where
I'm at right now and I'm I'm cooking I'm
baking it and I got all these ideas that
I'm really amped about
um and whether they make
you know whether they they whether you
guys like them whether they get views or
not is out of my control I have no
control over that all I can control
is how often I step up to work on the
art
um and
I can obviously make the art good right
I can try and make it as good as I can
but there's a process to it right and
that's where the creative act that Rick
Rubin book comes in he talks all about
the process the creative process and
it's so cool I never really thought
about it in the way that he brought it
up in this book which is
you go about life and you have all these
what he calls seeds and they're all like
idea starters they're all Sparks of an
idea and I have a little thing on my
phone it's just called seeds and I split
them up into music movies
um writing whatever right and I'll put
them down there and not anytime I'm like
I need I need an idea or not even I need
an idea it's like the more seeds that
you gather the more excited you'll be to
like you have a big list of exciting
things to do
and you go through and you mine them you
essentially like push them you you
experiment with a seed you see what it
can grow into and if you chop it off too
early
that's not the point the point is to let
it grow and see where it goes naturally
when you get to that point you let it
grow naturally you let these ideas come
about naturally and you you kind of
um
yeah say you have an idea for a video
what are all the different ways you
could do it what are all the different
ways you know it's not just one way it's
a bunch of different ways let's try
experimenting with X Y and Z with no
pressure that's another thing is
pressure is not good for creativity so
like deadlines is really tough to be
creative and open and experimental with
a deadline
is very difficult and I think that's
what the whole YouTube schedule thing is
so difficult is like oh I have to post
there's no time to create there's no
time to innovate there's no time to
experiment
so I don't and I end up just like not
being as ant about it as I would be if I
had taken the pressure away
and experimented and come like that's
how this Lego stuff came about
you know I found this book
that I talked about at the beginning of
um of the stream here
I loved the way this looked
I bought it on the spot
and I got an idea to make a video with
this kind of stuff
and when I went to Japan I had this idea
in mind
and I shot a bunch of footage
um without worrying whether it's gonna
be in the video or not I just shot a
bunch of footage
and um
you know came back and kind of went
through the footage and
did a little edit figured out what
um
what worked what didn't and I'm still
open I'm still as oh trying to be as
open as possible
um and there's no schedule for this
video either I'm just having fun with it
and we'll see when it's done it'll be
done when it's done
so I'm excited about that
um
but yeah I don't know that's kind of a
tangent there
um
Ronan peace out man thanks for for
joining me
hope you had a good time
um let's check the chat I know I said
hit me with your questions so let's
let's go through and hit with the
questions
what's my favorite photo that I took
while in Japan and why all right Alex
you brought it up let's do it I'm gonna
show you my film photos from Japan I got
them developed
recently
so let me show these to you guys and
pull them up here and kind of go through
them pretty quickly they're they're
there's about 70 photos I won't take too
long with it but um
there's a couple bangers in there you
know they're not all they're not all
great but
let's see what we got
so these are all taken on a holga it's a
plastic camera
it's in the other room it's a forty
dollar camera all right this is a forty
dollar plastic film camera medium format
film camera they all come out as uh like
Square One to One ratio format here
um you could do color black and white
XYZ the whole camera's plastic including
the lens and the glass everything
um and there's only f8 or f11 for the
aperture there's only one over 100 or
bulb which is you hold it down for as
long as you want for the shutter speed
the film stock which is technically your
ISO is uh baked into like whatever film
you buy
oh and focus the focus
um is person a few people a lot of
people or a mountain that's all you have
for focus and you're not even looking
into what you're seeing you're looking
into a rangefinder which is just like an
uh approximation it's just a piece of
glass looking through that's it
so it's kind of random almost and you
kind of you know you take some practice
but this is my first
my first run through we found this blue
penguin Bakers and uh
in takayama
see some of these didn't turn out right
this one's a little blurry but it's cool
I like it this was in takayama as well
which is like between Tokyo it's like a
triangle between Tokyo Kyoto and
takayama
um it's a very small town if you saw the
movie your name
the girl from the movie your name
um is from takayama and that's how we
found out about it this was my second
time in tokayama
this one I love the color on this and
also uh I just need to crop it but yeah
that'll be a cool one
if you guys recognize this that was the
train reference that we were working
with
shirakawago this is shirakala is outside
an hour outside of takayama and it's
this ancient place
these old thatched roof buildings
are just incredible
um
you know of course they're farming here
um and they have more modern houses next
to these like ancient thatched roof
houses
which is really cool
great reference here
and you guys may recognize this too I
showed you at the beginning but this is
like that little altar
a few more here let's see
um
yeah this is more shirakawago
and this was actually like a
like a tea and coffee place we went down
there and we got some amazing Curry it
was crazy
so good the flowers here are crazy too
it was uh springtime
when we went
and it's right up in this like Little
Valley
big old Forest behind it so beautiful
yeah and I just love shooting film I I
got back into it too you know I I
stopped shooting film for the longest
time but this trip got me back in this
is straight okay so this place is um
you might think they're similar but uh
this place is for real people live here
people live in these houses all right
this place is
in takayama proper and it is a open-air
museum they brought these buildings in
from different parts of Japan to
um you know as a museum they built this
place out which is crazy
and it was basically like
kakariko Village if you guys are playing
Zelda right now
um it's literally real life cockerico
Village which is so cool
and I went into this like
I've been making a lot of ambient music
recently this year
and I was like you know what this thing
shoots one to one square format so I'm
gonna just try and get a bunch of like
album art photos
so
that was fun see what else do we got
here
um this is cinestill 800t
um 800 tungsten and uh at this point I
was like over exposing I think
this was a Sumo match if you guys look
closely you can
see yeah soon we'll match here
everyone's lined up
pretty cool
this is at the Ghibli Museum outside the
Jimmy Museum
in mitaka this was the walk toward the
Giblin Museum beautiful park there
I I bought um
some treats from this woman here I took
a picture but it's yeah
I didn't uh
this was like right at the beginning of
the trip when I was still learning the
camera we did go-karts through Tokyo
which was so cool
there's an hour ride go-kart uh session
Mario Kart through Tokyo and it was the
best if you guys are gonna go to Tokyo
if you're gonna go to Japan check out
monkey cart that's uh the service that's
the those are the guys who put it
together yeah check out monkey cart it
was super fun
I love these shots
so much fun
it's another another underexposed one
this should have been better
there's just some people chilling
this guy I asked this guy if I could
take a picture of him he was sitting in
this garage and I guess I I double
exposed I I forgot to wind the film so
it stacked both images on top of each
other
um maybe this is there's something
salvageable here it's a pretty cool look
now that I'm looking at on the computer
um but uh yeah a little crop a little uh
a little distort a little warp get this
all squared up looking nice I think
there could be something here
album art wise I don't know
I love this one too it's just a color
the eight that 800 tungsten is one of
the best film stocks it's by a company
called uh sinistil and what they do is
they take Motion Picture film and they
convert it to
um photograph film photography so 35
millimeter 120 millimeter medium format
um if you guys are into shooting film
this is all like Motion Picture film
very Blade Runner looking
kind of stuff
they have a black and white stock
but the 800t is my favorite
um we got more stuff you know
album art
monkeys look at this baby monkey look at
this little baby monkey right here
this is um in Kyoto monkey Park
they're chilling little baby monkey
learning how to climb
so cute
this little guy and they it's funny they
put you in a cage right so these monkeys
are Roman free but you're in this little
Hut in this house here
um and you go in and then you feed them
and they're like give me more food give
me more food it's hilarious this place
is uh also in Kyoto this is a moss
Temple it's called kokedera okay Dara
Moss Temple
um and uh it's like a thousand year old
uh like a little Moss Forest
and um they have you like write a bunch
of like calligraphy before you do this
thing to like get your mind right you
know you gotta prepare for the forest
and then they send you on this walk
around the forest
um or around the lake which is just
beautiful
um and these pictures don't capture the
beauty
of this place
um but oh yeah I love this photo this
guy was like sweeping up all the leaves
and there's this boat out here
this this is one of my favorite shots
just this old man
observing I don't know a rock or
something
a little underexposed but honestly I
like the look and I can push it later
because these are um hi-res uh I think
these are jpegs huh
that's the Moss temple in Kyoto this is
more
um thatched roof business I was planning
on just cropping out this tree so it's
just like a kind of half and half image
this is back in takayama that open air
museum this is all the Open Air Museum
this woman oh my goodness so this is in
Tokyo this is the morning Market in
takayama on the river it's beautiful and
I actually photographed this woman like
on my last trip
four years ago five years ago
yeah five years ago maybe even six I
don't know
and uh she was still there and I showed
her the picture of her from from before
that I took before and I was and she was
like oh my God I'm so young
so I took another one of her it was cool
to see
to see the contrast
we have some kids just chilling this is
what basically this right here is behind
this right
and this is
if you tilt up that's what you're gonna
see here this is in takayama it's so
beautiful
so beautiful
this is uh on our way we drove
from Tokyo to takayama and this was one
of the views
this one is crazy so this was basically
that's a walkway this is a bridge
believe it or not a miniature like one
foot not even one I'm like literally
your foot wide Bridge a maintenance
bridge over a river
but yeah this was again towards the
beginning of the trip when I was still
figuring out my like exposure
blurry Tokyo
one more
this one I love I love the uh
you know I I always wind your film
forward so that you're ready to take a
shot
so I was walking down just this
beautiful place it's called um kibune I
think in Kyoto it's like 15 minute drive
north of Kyoto
um and it's just a road like this that
just goes up into the mountain and
there's a river that runs along the
um
it runs down the mountain and they have
all these restaurants
built over the river it's crazy so
you're like sitting down enjoying tea
and like watching a waterfall
this guy was just passing I was like oh
perfect
a little underexposed you know but it is
what it is this is in Kyoto
on the the river at around golden hour
and none of these really were the one
you know I was waiting for some someone
to to Bike by you see everyone there's
every one of these I'm waiting for
someone to Bike by or walk by but none
of them really weren't it and that's
fine
you know they let me take a picture of
them by the
by the uh what is it the Pagoda probably
would have framed it a little bit
different but you know it's okay
this was the Kyo mizudera temple in
Kyoto and that's the most popular Temple
ever it was maxed out ridiculous
that's it yeah that was the Japan trip
so to answer your question probably the
the shot of the the old man standing and
looking out over uh looking at that rock
that might have been my favorite shot
um this one this one is great too I like
this one as well
but um
yeah it was just fun to shoot film again
honestly
all right let's see any other questions
read any good books recently you know I
read um there was a book
called
Street of a thousand blossoms and it was
a it was a book about um sumo wrestler
and I picked it up because we were going
to watch a Sumo match in Japan so I
picked it up to like get a little bit of
insight on what Sumo is like so to have
a better appreciation for the match
I got about halfway through
watch the match and then the match gave
me a better appreciation for the book it
was pretty good book if the characters
were amazingly written felt like they
were real
um of course the creative act by Rick
Rubin uh the artist's way
um
her name is uh something Cameron Julie
Cameron Julie Cameron I think
um that that's absolutely incredible
it's like a workbook creative workbook
that you do uh once a day and it breaks
up into like 12 weeks and that really
helped me kind of
I don't know re reintegrate and get get
creative again I felt like I was
creatively stifled in and that really
helped me
um that's what I'm working on now I'm
reading a book called seven Eves by Neil
Stevenson at the moment it's like sci-fi
book the opening the opening sentence is
the moon blew up without warning
um
and for no reason at all
yeah that's how the book starts that's
the first the first sense so good
ah wondrous okay so you you feel it too
you said when your back rooms videos
blew up you got tired of making them so
you switched to making videos you like
doing yeah
Styles Morales what's up man thanks for
the
or the the kind words
oh Ben okay so if an idea for a project
suddenly becomes much less interesting
how do you get yourself excited about it
again
that's a good question so
um
I don't know I don't know and there's
probably not a right answer for this but
here here's what
might happen is maybe maybe you've moved
on past the idea you know maybe you
you're a different person every day you
wake up right
um you're a different person the next
week the next month the next year
so you may have had an idea x amount of
days ago weeks months years ago that was
so exciting to you and it's just not
really there for you anymore and that's
okay that just means you have
kind of grown or changed
the idea itself Also may not have been
as
awesome as you may have thought it was
to you
when you first came up with it too so
there's that
so I don't know if it's not exciting to
you anymore then it's just not exciting
to you anymore that's okay
um you know we we change with the days
so
um
if nothing's exciting to you anymore now
then that that's a different thing but
another thing you could do is you could
take that idea and you can start asking
questions about it like how could I do
that what was exciting to me originally
about this and you can just write about
that
um I think that would be helpful in
trying to find the core of what was
exciting to you originally about that
and journaling to yourself maybe talking
it out with a friend and then figuring
out you know maybe I am still excited
about this because
you know I broke it down and I figured
out what it is that I'm excited about or
you know I think this originally excited
me not so excited about it anymore and
that's okay
um let's see let's see
Roman hey what's up man from Ukraine
nice dude um
you started learning Unreal Engine five
[Music]
um and watching my tutorials that's
great congrats man keep it up keep it up
stay safe out there
um hopefully you and your family are
doing all right
[Music]
Ali Reza thank you for the kind words I
really appreciate it
guys I think um I think that's it I
think we're going to
to call it there thank you for joining
me I had a blast that was truly truly a
good time building out that uh that Lego
train with y'all and I'm excited to keep
building that Lego stuff I got a cool
video coming out I don't know when it'll
be
um but you know keep an eye out for it
in the meantime weekly challenge is
running right now we got a challenge
going on this week check the Discord
link below
um we're gonna do a Lego one next as
soon as as soon as uh it's probably next
week because I think the the weekly
challenge has already decided for this
this upcoming week but we're doing uh
we're doing Lego next time
uh check out Bricklink it's cool again
not sponsored I'm just a big fan of it
um I discovered it in trying to recreate
these Legos
and um yeah it's a cool program very
very fun
pretty darn addicting actually
so have fun with it yeah have a good
time if you're trying to bring those
cloud files into c4d I got that
converter for you in the description as
well and of course if you guys want to
support me more videos like this I do
have a patreon as well so go check that
out
I got two tiers five dollar Community
tier 30 Pro tier
uh Pro tier gets access to all my assets
that I ever put out
um I know it's not as as frequent it's
not updated daily like a quick little
Bridge or anything
um but you know there's a good chunk of
stuff uh uploaded in their asset-wise so
yeah go check it out I appreciate you
guys thank you so much for everything
um I'll catch you soon I don't know
exactly when but uh you know I'll be
cranking on stuff
and I'll see you on the Discord right
and uh what else
what else I think that's about it guys
um you know uh Community challenge the
new community challenge I don't know
what the idea is yet but I got I have
some ideas
and that's gonna be in August okay
working month is in August so yeah keep
keep hanging out keep doing these
weeklies keep having fun I'll catch you
guys soon peace out later y'all
[Music]
thank you